so let's talk about this article from
newrepublic.com
by uh seth simons have you read this
article
have you read this a bit can i can i
summer i know i haven't but can i let me
guess
sure uh comedy is toxic
the stand bad stand the stand
bad comedy toxic gas digital bad lewis
jay gomez bad
toxic masculinity and comedy bad
the comedy industry has a big problem
it's it's like i could write your life
story for you seth
you're a one you are literally the most
one
note douchebag on the planet how safe
space is for a transgressive humor both
online and real life help read a hateful
ideology
this guy just won't stop man
in the dark recesses of the internet
lurks a man who goes by
toxic cis white male fat
he's made his home on the ona forums.net
a community named after the shock talk
to opiate anthony
a safe pace a safe space to say what
cannot be said offline
he's posted in threads like uh n word
hate thread number one
the k hate the k word hate thread
juno comes out as a wait did the o a
people really just buy
a message board and make sub sections
called
n-word hate and k-word well in threads
it was a thread called n-word hate
thread
uh the k-word hate thread uh and also
juno comes out
and official post-election voter fraud
threat
where he called joe biden who's about to
die in the oval office
[Laughter]
that's that's the only subreddit well
whatever message board
elsewhere he derided the kova 19 vaccine
which he calls
juice so wait a minute has seth simon's
now to the point where he's just now
picking out
random message board posters that is
correct and writing entire articles
about them yes
hey seth this is why nobody respects you
and and it's weird right because you
failed at comedy
so then you went into journalism for
comedy but you're failing at journalism
so you're like a man without a world
you're like the stringer bell
of the comedy industry you're not quite
gangster enough for one world
and you're not quite the businessman
enough for the other you're a man
without a country
seth nobody likes you not even your
editor that has to [ __ ]
post these [ __ ] stories hey at least
stringerbot went to college
elsewhere he derided the covet 19
vaccine which he calls
juice and and i quote
[Music]
cheeky sauce [ __ ]
sauce maybe he's writing this stuff
because it's
[ __ ] hilarious last year he revealed
that his twitter account
ap von tarksin the username matches a
commentator on thought catalog
which toxic toxic cis white male fat
has said he trolled after it retracted
phobic essay by the proud boys founder
gavin mcginnis
steven his contributions there were more
of the same under a 2015 post titled
when you love the chase he once
commented there is not more despicable
human on earth than a
fat white n-word [ __ ] get an
aids test you have it
the internet can sometimes be one big
rabbit hole
and if you make it down to the bottom
waiting for you as a waiting for you at
the person
waiting for you as a person at the
bottom of mind was toxic cis white male
fat
i've spent the last five years writing
about the comedy industry in the last
three or so covering
inequality and extremism within it yeah
because you're not [ __ ] doing comedy
anymore obviously
10 bucks says this guy is just nick
mullen this was
anonymously posting on the boards this
work has periodically brought me in
contact with some of the leading lights
in the scene's
transgressive edge the place where
popular mainstream comedy bleeds into
the kind of
right-wing political politics that
animated the capital right
last month it's a place hostile to
prying eyes and the
blowback can be furious i have been
harassed and trolled on social media
mostly by louis j gomez though
i have been doxxed as uh as have members
of my family and eventually i found my
way to message boards where toxic cis
white male
fat who i have a reason to believe
thought i cannot definitively prove
is the person at the heart of the new
york city club comedy scene oh you're
about to get there can i just point out
something before we get into
all of the points of this article that i
will predict 100 accurately because seth
simons again is just a one-night note
broken record
seth simons is you know when there's
like a kid right that's just getting his
ass beat every day in school
right because there is a difference
between just brutally picking on the
same kid every day
but i'm sure you remember growing up and
i remember growing up there was always
that kid that would get bullied but like
he'd start it there was always kids like
that that would like
they'd put themselves in situations to
be bullied
yeah it's not like some kids went hey
loser
we're beating you up today it's the kid
that was like we didn't get all the
homework
or it's the kid that tattles or it's the
kid that like says some [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] other kids and then they start
beating him up every day
then he goes to the principal and goes
i'm i'm being
bullied every day and it's like but
you're just don't engage like louis j
gomez didn't just go like hey let's [ __ ]
with seth simon's doggy like
he just kept needling them and needling
them and then they all started mocking
him mercilessly
and then he's like but i got doxed and
it's like that's what you do that for a
living you dox people for a living
that's what this whole thing is
he was calling the new york health
department to tattletail on the stand
that they were having shows there
so but that's what i'm saying so there
are
you know look i'll be the first to say
you know it's a hack take to go like
bullying's good it's not always good
like
just picking on random kids isn't good
bullying is good in the context of
like that scene in full metal jacket
when he had the jelly donut and then
everybody got in trouble and they wailed
on him with bars of soap
that's accepted bullying it's like you
did something
you're [ __ ] my [ __ ] up now i'm going
to beat you up but seth simon's the
perfect example of
i'm being picked on and it's like then
stop [ __ ] with those kids
stop [ __ ] with them they're going to
keep beating you up oh i hate this man
though i cannot definitely prove it
definitively prove it
it's a person at the heart of the new
york city club comedy scene
and others participated in the gamergate
style campaign that has been conducted
against me
oh me me me me me he's a white woman the
online forum
just one node in a constellation of
similar forums
subreddits and discord groups is not
some outlier in the industry
before i take you down my particular
rabbit hole it's worth establishing the
many ways in which the world of comedy
and the racist right overlap reinforce
each other
insufferable the recent comedy boom in
popularity
understood as an era in which new forms
of media like podcasts and streaming
videos create massive new audience for
comedy
two other things that you by the way
failed at seth
which in turn created a massive new
revenue stream for comedians
at the same time the artificial intimacy
of these platforms allowed fans to feel
level of
connection with their favorite
performers and
which end with each other this could
verge on the cultish
this was not simply an error of glorious
bounty in which
little-known comedians would land
massive netflix
netflix paydays or leapfrog from ucb
comedy to college humor to lucrative
sitcom writing gigs
it was also the area the era of walled
off salt
cultures like onaforms.net which could
transform into
real violent political factions
especially at a time
when comedy was increasingly pitted
against the forces of political
correctness
the very forces that also fueled the
grievous the grievances of donald trump
supporters
and the relev uh and the chauvinist
right
whose credo of owning the libs reads a
lot like the traditional
comedy comedians defense of right to
insult and be offended
i want to just to for those of you that
don't really know much about
seth simons seth simons is known for
being a guy that failed at comedy that's
what he did he did comedy he did
that hipster brooklyn coffee shop comedy
he was terrible at it
and he ended up somehow starting to
become the
comedy correspondent for the new york
times
and what he did was he set out after
failing at comedy
to get back at everybody that ever
[ __ ] told him he sucked at it
and now he's out to he's literally been
out
to destroy comedy it's been his this guy
has some sort of
weird vengeance this bitter like i'm
he's
he's angry at them and he he couldn't
make it
he's even pointing out in this article
it gave way to all these walled off
communities and you're angry that you
couldn't build one
you're angry that you were neither
interesting charismatic or funny enough
to build the community around yourself
so now you just go around and snitch out
everybody to the new york times
he's the most miserable spiteful
sad little man in all of [ __ ] comedy
and [ __ ]
even even at the new york times seth
simons is the biggest loser there
uh the the mobs that descended on
washington dc last month
and by the way this isn't the new york
times he's in the new republic oh he's
in the new republic well he used to
write stuff for the new york times i'm
just letting you know this article sorry
the mobs that descended on washington dc
last month have intellectual roots in
many places going back to the bloody
beginnings of this country
but they also have roots in specific
areas of modern culture including
facebook buzzfeed in the increasingly
online world of comedy
all the forces that incubate the rioters
are still there unchanged chugging along
as normal
the rot goes much deeper than you might
expect do you know why you're not funny
seth
because this is how your brain works
your brain works in this
gas nerd kind of way where it's like
you want to write about the painful
birth of this nation while talking about
a couple of new york clubs
that that sell overpriced watered-down
drinks while you watch
rich vosko ah come on you know shuttle
down
like or whatever the [ __ ] like that's
all it is you
these these sort of like brooklyn
hipster people are the ones that ruined
comedy because they're the ones that
came out with the
why can't we speak truth to power and
make comedy like
a high art form and it's like it's not
it's literally guys
showing up to a club telling some
[ __ ] dick jokes you buying drinks and
everybody goes home
when you overthink it you suck at comedy
seth simon's
sucked at comedy i
make me violently angry if the far
right's origins in comedy are
ill-appreciated
and they were never particularly secret
by his own account gavin mcginnis
created the proud boys on compound media
a subscriber-based digital network where
he hosted a talk show from 2015 to 2017
originally called the anthony coumney
network compound media was created in
2014 by cumia
the anthony half of opium anthony after
his firing from sirius xm
over a series of racist tweets the gavin
mcguinness show like many other programs
on the self-styled free speech network
was not shy about its politics over the
show's 407 episodes
mcginnis spoke glowingly of right-wing
violence proudly declaring himself a
racist and regularly used the n-word
among other slurs when a caller
questioned his interracial marriage in
2016 mcginnis responded
that he had children with a woman of
color because he's cleaning up the races
look whether you like mcguinness or not
mcginnis was clearly making up
that's he was clearly making a joke
even reading it i could tell that's a
joke and i hate to admit it but gavin
can be funny
kevin of course is funny [ __ ] sometimes
i'm like goddamn that was good
the pretense of irony hung over
everything he said but the pretense is
all
is all it ever was compound media was
where telling
jokes gave way to saying what you meant
jokingly
remember now comedy always used to be
like you should be able to joke about
anything you should be [ __ ] people
like
bill hicks uh [ __ ]
the amount of comedians that fought for
you to say whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
and now these [ __ ] nerds that have
infected
every other every other medium
everything that infected everything are
also
trying to come into comedy and tell you
uh you're not allowed to joke about that
sweaty if your joke isn't about orange
man bad
get off the stage [ __ ] you the reason
that these walled off communities were
created
wasn't it was a reaction to the [ __ ]
you're doing it was to get away from you
yeah it was a reaction to this and then
the reactionary
when these communities started to they
weren't [ __ ] with you
they weren't [ __ ] with you dude they
were they just like you said they were
walled off
they just wanted to have their little
area and go like look man
i'm never going to be on snl i'm never
going to get a tv deal
you know youtube's never going to push
us up in the algorithm so let's cut a
deal let's all just go over here
we'll leave you alone you leave us alone
the problem is you just simply are
incapable of
leaving people alone it's
it it's it's inherent in certain people
who you know are in the media media
journalists
journalists in general are just terrible
and uh
again seth is a guy that you can tell
from his old videos
he really wanted to be a comedian but
he wasn't funny uh hack the movies says
uh who cares about compound media
it's all about opie radio true how come
opi radio is not getting any write-ups
because he can't do the sunsets anymore
because of covid ah
that'll do it every single time man well
you don't want to watch 50 videos of the
same
50 of the same videos of a middle-aged
guy with the camera pointed at the
hudson river while he's going
dude i don't even care anymore i don't
even dude
i don't even care anymore i'm so past it
you don't want to do that anymore i
think that's great
um when when mcginnis founded the proud
boys in 2016
he used tgms as a recruitment tool
this in his monologue and call-in
segments he laid out the organization's
principles and customs
chief among which was its ideology of
western chauvinism
a belief in the superiority of western
civilization and the white people
supposedly responsible for it
white males are a big part of what makes
the west great he told the caller
without question
they are but he's again gavin is correct
you know what i love my fate one of my
favorite cops that i always hear from
like especially about black people is
they always go uh black people
built this nation and you're like do you
honestly think
they used slaves to build cathedrals
and city halls and like these big
plantation houses
do you really think slaves were used to
gather materials to pick cotton
it's like just a thing they did they
were used for farming they were used for
labor but do you really think that like
i love when they go slaves built this
country no let's be fair a bunch of
grease ball
italian stone masons were brought over
and paid next to nothing the chinese and
the italians
built this country and the supervised
that's if we're being fair and the dutch
was their uber
that's really pretty much it yeah they
just kept bringing over ships of lumber
despite his concerns that the openly
element of the far right
were bad for his brand mcginnis didn't
hesitate to associate with them
his guests were a who's who of
contemporary far right
milo richard spencer unite the right
rally organizer jason kessler okay we've
interviewed him
christopher cantwell mike cernovich
faith
faith goldie goldie
david duke who who makes the mayonnaise
i'm sorry
doctor david duke okay
put some respect on his name he didn't
get some dodgy [ __ ] doctorate in some
made-up
category for you to disrespect him like
that
in retrospect the gavin beginner show's
function was not just to introduce the
comedy world to the
world that's what it was what a leap
what a [ __ ] leap
but to let one the one legitimize the
other at this time mcginnis was widely
successful
his influence long outlasting in his own
tenure in the new york comedy scene
in 2017 dave smith as you know dave
smith
uh used a tv dave smith tg well
it's funny you say skinhead dave smith
dave smith used the tgms uh guest
hosting spot to interview richard
spencer and christopher cantwell
giving both a friendly platform to lay
out their vision for a white
ethno state by then he and the other two
legionist gank members had left compound
media for a network founded by gomez
gas digital where they care i'm gonna
win this bingo watch
where they carried out the tgms
tradition racism sexism homophobia
phobia and flirtation with the far right
today if if if he mentions the stand i
get bingo
i'm waiting for i got my little you know
the little boop things
the ink things i'm sitting here with my
cards all laid out and i'm like come on
come on give it to me give me the stand
today's legion of skanks holds a
considerable swaying comedy
with a massive platform he's jealous it
lent
it lent everyone who's anyone in the new
york club scene
while remaining true to its far right
roots in 2019 it hosted milo
after his fall from grace in 2018 gomez
angrily chased a fan out of a recording
when the man pointed out a proud boy in
the audience
you were joking this next sentence dave
smith
a sympathizer who believes
run forces that are killing society
has become a powerful voice in the right
flank of the libertarian party
i've never honestly maybe i've maybe i'm
not listening to enough dave smith but i
don't ever hear dave smith doing jq
stuff
yeah neither do i i maybe i maybe i'm
wrong here like i don't think dave smith
is the kind of guy to deny like
you know certain industries certainly
seem to favor them but like i don't
think
dave smith would be out there going you
know what the problem is
yeah i don't think he does that uh he's
used his own podcast on gas digital to
pal around with white supremacists like
cantwell spencer and nick fuentes now
pal around so this is this is the new
thing that's happening right
whenever you have somebody on even if
you completely disagree with them
and you have them on your show to to
have a discussion and be like hey man
why do you think the way you think and
you have a back and forth
now you're paling around larry king has
had clan members skinheads
go down the [ __ ] list of the [ __ ]
people that larry king's had on his show
was he paddling around with them you
you're allowed to interview whoever the
[ __ ] you want
and by your own standards then why was
tim hi decker paddling around with nick
fuentes
why was why were vic berger and tim
hydeker having a [ __ ] laugh fest
with their good friend nick fuentes do
you see how stupid that sounds
yeah so it's these guys are so selective
in their outrage
and i there's i i'm trying to really
think i don't think there's anybody
right now out there
in this like sphere that i hate more
than seth simons
he's the most despicable person
anywhere in around new york comedy he's
the worst
if i can use the government to do
horrific things to the left i will
because they've been doing horrific
things to us for centuries
cantwell told him on the united told
them after the unite the right rally in
2017.
smith agreed it's almost like you're
having a conversation with somebody and
they punch you in the face the
ideological response
is to get up and fight would extrema
would extremism have found such a loving
home in comedy without mcginnis
maybe much of the blame also goes to the
man who gave him a platform during the
alt-right's formative years
anthony kumia a racist trump supporter
who pled guilty to domestic abuse
charges in 2016.
kumia certainly shares much of
mcginnis's ideology
he spent six years with uh with
reactionaries like ann coulter
alex jones we've had him on the show
donald uh trump jr on compound media's
uh program the anthony kumia show with
dave landau
the network as a whole straddles the
same world as tgms
on one side it's a breeding ground for
far-right ideology
on the other regular old gig for pretty
much every club comic in new york city
yeah by a [ __ ]
ripe thing you mean people still doing
good fellas impressions and stuff then
yeah you're in the right place
in some cases the line is completely
blurred compound host
chrissy maher has lately delved deep
into the
conspiracy theories believing and
spreading them that is and attending the
protest at capitol hill on january 6th
aaron berg and gino bisconti host in hot
water a show
whose recurring segments include black
guy of the day
isis and rape of the day these comics
are all regulars at the new york city
club
you got your thing you got your thinking
for bingo bingo
what did i tell you the stand
that's a bingo
is that the way you say that's a bingo
you just say bingo
bingo how fun
thank you this guy is such a [ __ ]
one note loser it's
the same [ __ ] song
he's been playing the same tune for like
four years now this guy is such a
[ __ ]
jealous loser oh can i point out that
dave smith is jewish
uh it's unlikely many bookers know they
built their followings on a network that
caters to far right but some do okay hey
[ __ ]
even if you get rid of all the far right
people they're still not going to book
you seth
you get that right you're still not
going to get the gig you could try to
get rid of everybody
but you're not funny enough to do it
yourself see there's a difference
they're still gonna
find somebody who'll say the woke [ __ ]
you say
but be funny you're never going to
be funny that's the problem do you know
why
do you know why people like doing stuff
on gas digital
and like doing stuff with louis j gomez
and like doing stuff these guys
at the stand because at least from our
experience that they treat people
really nicely yeah they're very nice
they're funny guys
they do funny [ __ ] and like it's a good
time like you go you do their show and
you go these guys are great
it's a blast like everybody's being nice
they're inviting you places
i didn't get any vibe that anybody there
was was
hosting any secret clan rallies in fact
everybody i met at gas digital had the
same mission which was like
whenever you [ __ ] up somewhere because
there's this place we can go get [ __ ]
up
but there's also this place where you
can go get [ __ ] up and he'd be like oh
let's go get that
joker invited me to a clan rally oh dude
yeah he wears the gloves to cover up
swats because he has on his
on his hands he's got he's got a bunch
of [ __ ] he's got
some words let's just say he's got words
on his knuckles that he doesn't want
dave
smith to see yeah specifically i'm just
putting you that way okay
let's just say he told me he wished he
had 14 fingers
and 88 toes